viel zu viele leute sehen nur einmal im
frühling ihr gemüse aus dann haben sie
einmal im sommer eine ganz große ernte
schwämme und danach können sie wieder in
laden rennen und sich ihr gemüse da
kaufen um das zu verhindern muss man das
ganze jahr immer wieder kleinere mengen
aussehen auch jetzt im juni und welche
gemüse jetzt in die erde kommen das
zeige ich euch wir starten mit den
aussagen die man jetzt im haus machen
kann oder im gewächshaus ich habe meine
antwort jetzt ins gewächshaus verlagert
weil mein freund die krise kriegt wenn
das ganze jahr über töpfe bei uns im
badezimmer stehen und ich starte mit dem
salat so leitet sie an gemüse das
relativ schnell wächst und der salat der
geht jetzt im sommer auch relativ
schnell in die blüte so dass dieser
leute die jetzt vielleicht noch für euch
im beet stehen bald schon gar nicht mehr
so lecker sind das heißt man muss immer
wieder nachsehen und im sommer stehe ich
total auf eine sorte die heißt pirat wie
bei euch deswegen an weil die super
schoss fest ist das heißt die fängt
längst nicht so schnell an zu blühen wie
die anderen salate und außerdem sehe ich
auch noch eine sorte aus little gem
heißt die einfach weil ich sie super
lecker finde das hier ist der prachtkerl
der little gem und die streusel ich
jetzt einfach oben auf die erde auf und
drückte sie leicht an das sind nämlich
licht kaymer die darf man nicht mit erde
bedecken ich sehe jetzt in ein töpfchen
und pick hier die später in ihrer
eigenen töpfchen wenn die aufgegangen
sind das macht man immer wenn die mehr
als zwei blätter haben ich habe da meine
ball brause dabei um die genesung
bisschen an zu wässern
das ist immer ganz wichtig nach dem
auszählen immer schön gut an gießen auch
damit die samen richtig boden schluss
bekommen wir machen weiter mit dem
populi ich merke allerdings gerade das
hier überhaupt keine samen mehr drin
sind habe ich mir ein leeres tütchen
zurecht gesucht deswegen halte ich den
euch jetzt einfach mal in die kamera
broccoli kann man jetzt also auch
anbauen das hier ist eine meiner
absoluten lieblings sollten die heißt
harmlose calabrese machen wir weiter mit
dem wai school of sales die sollte der
maler aus das ist meine lieblings dabei
traut sollte
jeder von euch denn noch nie sauerkraut
gemacht hat aber gerne welches ist
worauf wartet ihr soll ich mein video
zum song laut herstellen machen wird
euch das interessieren schreibt mir das
gerne mal jetzt kommt ein gemüse dass
ich eigentlich gar nicht so gerne esse
aber ab und zu kommt schon bei uns im
garten
das heißt ich euch jetzt auch einfach
mal nur in die kamera weil ich kann
nicht jedes mal wenn es möglich ist
kohlrabi aussehen und am ende ist die
niemand bei uns aber gabby geht jetzt
auch machen wir weiter mit zwei
klassischen winter gemüsen und damit
kommt jetzt auch hier die erinnerung
nochmal jetzt ist die zeit in der die
wintergemüse in die erde müssen wenn ihr
im winter immer noch gemüse in ihrem
garten stehen haben wollt dann müsst ihr
das jetzt auswählen egal ob im haus ins
beet oder direkt nach draußen pflanzen
deswegen kommen hier in diesem video
ganz viele wintergemüse vor wie zum
beispiel der grünkohl und der palm cool
sein cool ist dass die politik da baue
ich ganz gern die sollte nero die
toskana an und beim grünkohl sehe ich
die sorte westländer winter aus die
kommen auch wieder wie eigentlich alle
gemüse die wir heute sehen alle in ein
schälchen und werden dann später in
einzelne schälchen zitiert wenn sie
nicht mehr um kein blatt stadium sind
also wenn sie ihre ersten laubblätter
haben das sind ein paar viele samen nah
kommt wieder zurück
zum beschriften verwende ich wieder die
als stäbchen und auch immer wenn
bleistift beschriften weil sonst
superschnell die farbe abgewaschen kein
größerer super-chance gemüse oder
essen den gar nicht so gerne aber ich
liebe einfach wie ein bild aussieht noch
so ein oberflächliches gemüse ist der
zirkus das ist ein wunderschöner unter
kohl den man den ganzen winter über
ernten kann und der sollte jetzt auch in
die erde kommen
da mache ich mir jetzt auch noch ein
töpfchen vollen der ist super forsthart
und wunderschön also und es lag also der
pool ist ja auch black an aber ich mag
das ist auch ein bisschen bunt ist im
beet ein bisschen die gemüse auch ein
bisschen was hermachen und gemüsegarten
kann ja wunderschön sein sondern mehr
noch amaranth
brand ist die sorte
rotkohl rotkraut dieser ist am rand der
kann jetzt auch noch ausgewählt werden
ist schon relativ spät im juni also wenn
ihr noch rot grünen euren garten
pflanzen wollt dann rissen sie hat es
eine gute gelegenheit das noch zu
erledigen jetzt sehe ich auch noch
wirsing aus auch wieder ein winter
gemüse an dass man jetzt wirklich denken
sollte damit es dann im winter auch reif
ist weil die ganzen gemüse die müssen
bevor es richtig kalt wird groß werden
weil wenn es ganz kalt ist dann können
sie gar nicht mehr so wirklich weiter
wachsen und ich wenig da sehr enttäuscht
seit im winter und denkt ich hätte ja zu
gerne meinen garten voller gemüse man
kann ja unglaublich viele gemüse auch im
winter anbauen kann ich euch gerne
meinen video in der video beschreibung
verlinken wo ich erzähle welche gemüse
man denn im winter alle anbauen kann
aber dann ist es vielleicht schon zu
spät wenn ihr dann erst daran denkt
machen wir weiter mit denen genießen die
man jetzt direkt nach draußen ins bett
zu ändern und da starten wir mit den
bohnen sowohl die busspuren als auch die
stangenbohnen kann man jetzt direkt ins
freiland säen die muss man auch nicht im
haus vorziehen das machen manche leute
ich halte das immer für ein bisschen
überflüssig wenn sie so gut im freiland
aufgehen und so schnell wachsen dann
denke ich kann man sich die an sucht oft
sparen und damit seinen gartenpflege
leichter machen weniger im garten zu tun
haben das ja immer mein motto und die
buschbohnen die sehe ich auch das ganze
jahr über immer wieder aus in kleinen
umsätzen einen zum haltbarmachen weil
wir super gerne bohnen fermentieren die
sind so unglaublich lecker hat das
jemand von euch schon mal ausprobiert
der hammer ich kann mich da rein legen
ich muss dieses jahr noch viel viel mehr
boden fermentieren deswegen bei euch
einen ganz großen buschbohnen satz an wo
ich ganz viele auf einmal sehe und alle
anderen sätze also alle anderen aussaat
chargen sind ein bisschen kleiner um
einfach laufend am band immer wieder
frische bohnen ernten zu können aber mit
den stangen boden mache ich das nicht
die sehr ich einmal am rand gerüst aus
dann wachsen wie und dann bleiben die da
bis zum herbst nur bei den buschbohnen
straße ich das super gerne weil sie noch
ein bisschen schneller wachsen und da
lohnt sich das noch ein bisschen mehr
machen wir weiter mit ein paar
wurzelgemüse das sind 1 die radieschen
die kann man ja eh rund ums jahr sehen
die wachsen auch super super schnell
rote beete kann jetzt auch in die erde
die kann man auch immer wieder aussehen
so dass man immer wieder tolle rote
beete ernten kann weil es übrigens schon
super schön hier im frühbeet kasten das
hat richtig gut geklappt dieses jahr und
dann kann man jetzt auch wieder karotten
aus serien pastinaken würden auch noch
gehen ich finde es aber relativ spät die
erst im juni zu sehen also lieber ab
februar und märz anfangen damit die noch
schön dick werden können aber wenn ihr
noch keine gesellschaft und denkt oder
die muss ich unbedingt noch im garten
haben könnt ihr das jetzt auch noch
machen bei den karotten dadurch wieder
die sorte milan an das ist die sommer
karotte die wir anbauen auch zum
einlagern also auch die die auf eine
größere menge an bauen wenn lust hat
jener ehrt miete oder einer kiste im
keller einzuschlagen so dass man den
winter über immer noch karotten essen
kann die kann man im winter auch im beet
stehen lassen solange man keine probleme
mit wühlmäusen hat schmecken die sogar
noch ein bisschen besser weil dann
richtig süß werden auch für den
salatteller ist jetzt wieder was dabei
einmal natürlich der ganz normale
saladin kann man jetzt auch sehr gut
einfach ins freiland säen man kann ist
nur wichtig dass er schön feucht bleibt
also wenn es im juni schon ein bisschen
trocken ist dann gut angießen und immer
schön feucht halten ruhig mehrmals am
tag ließen wenn man den gerade gewählt
hat um es nicht regnet dann spinat könnt
ihr jetzt aussehen das so eine sache
also spinat schießt seit im sommer super
schnell das heißt der beat bildet
superschnell blüten es gibt aber eine
sorte die ich kenne bestimmt gibt es
noch mehr aber dies relativ chance fest
das ist die sorte gerson und weil wir
spinat unglaublich lecker finden
versuchen wir damit im sommer auch
spinat anzubauen man muss ihn dann aber
relativ zügig ernten bevor er blüht also
nicht zu lange mit der ernte warten das
nicht vertrödeln ansonsten kann man
jetzt auch noch wunderbar hochschule
aussehen wir machen das nicht weil der
sand sich jedes jahr wieder neu aus bei
uns und das ist super praktisch gerade
wenn man den wilden rucola an bord und
nicht den kultur rucola der auch ein
bisschen besser schmecken finden dann
es ist super praktisch wenn wir einfach
einmal im garten ist dann sich immer
wieder weiter vermehren kann das mache
ich ganz gerne mit den pflanzen wo das
so einfach ist zum beispiel auch mit dem
portulak der sahen sich auch jedes jahr
neu aus und wächst quasi wild in unserem
garten und gurken und zucchini sollte
man jetzt auch noch mal im freiland
aussehen ich hab das ja im
gurkenpflanzen video das da oben
verlinkt ist auch schon mal cd doch
egal jedenfalls habe ich ja in dem video
schon erzählt dass die gurken ganz oft
von mehltau befallen werden und da ist
es ganz klug wenn man jetzt im juni
vielleicht mitte juni anfang juni noch
mal ein paar frische gurken direkt ins
beet das mache ich auch so mit insulin
er sich pflanze eine mitte mai und dann
sehe ich noch mal eine jetzt im juni aus
so dass die alten pflanzen wenn es ihn
schon nicht mehr so gut gilt ein
bisschen unterstützung haben von den
jüngeren pflanzen wieder ein richtig
ranklotzen und trotzdem noch weiter
gurken und zucchini liefern machen wir
weiter mit den gemüsen die man jetzt aus
pflanzen kann also fertige pflänzchen
die man entweder aus der gärtnerei
bekommen hat oder selbst im haus
vorgezogen hat ein kandidat wenn auch
der kürbis ich versuche den immer mitte
mai zum pflanzen weil der relativ viel
zeit im bad braucht frisch aussehen im
beet würde ich den jetzt im juni nicht
mehr aber wenn ihr noch fern sich in
habt oder noch pflänzchen bekommt dann
pflanzt auch jetzt noch eure kürbis
pflänzchen das geht im juni auf jeden
fall noch und dann kommen noch ein paar
kohlgemüse die man jetzt auch noch
pflanzen kann und sollte stichwort
wintergemüse der rosenkohl muss jetzt
ins beet der grünkohl man kann jetzt
auch noch kohlrabi pflanzen und brokkoli
weißkohl und blumenkohl funktionieren
jetzt auch noch ich selbst auch noch
meine runde chicorée aus der erste den
ich vor ein paar wochen gesetzt habe der
ist irgendwie nicht aufgegangen keine
ahnung warum aber das geht jetzt immer
noch und das ist super schön wenn man
dann im winter seine eigenen chicorée
wurzel einschlagen kann und dem keller
treiben kann wenn draußen nicht so
wirklich gutes wetter ist dann kann man
im haus immer noch weiter gärtnern also
wenn die kugel dann ab damit in die der
jetzt habt ihr gerade noch so eine
chance dafür juni wenn du jetzt noch
ganz am anfang steht und noch gar nicht
so viel planers von gemüse anbauen dann
schaue auf jeden fall mal da drüben
vorbei da habe ich nämlich eine
schritt-für-schritt-anleitung für dich
zusammengestellt wie man das macht wenn
man sein eigenes gemüse anbauen möchte
aber gar nicht so richtig weiß wo man
anfangen soll und ich glaube dass auch
die alten hasen unter euch da den einen
oder anderen tipp mit abgreifen können
ansonsten geht raus macht die welt ein
bisschen grüner und wir sehen uns am
samstag um 10 für ein neues video zu